[Musik]
waren aus der ganzen Welt häufig günstig
und ständig verfügbar ein Ergebnis der
Globalisierung wird dies künftig so
bleiben oder müssen wir uns auf neue
Zeiten einstellen es gibt Kräfte die die
Welt von Grund auf
verändern es geht um Autokratie gegen
Demokratie wir haben eine verschwindende
Weltordnung keine neue wenn die Welt in
einem schlechten Zustand ist dann ist
das schlecht für die Außenwirtschaft
Globalisierung wird für Deutschland
überlebenswichtig letztendlich sein aber
wird der freie Welthandel so wie wir ihn
kennen überleben sind wir für die
Zukunft gerüstet worauf kommt es dabei
an wer ist heute dein Freund wer ist
morgen noch dein Freund das ist es ist
entscheidend für die Industrie die
Oberhand zu behalten lieferstops können
dazu führen dass die Bänder in den
Fabriken auch in deut zum schstand
kommen haben wir uns zu abhängig gemacht
geht die Globalisierung zu
Ende was würde das für Deutschland
bedeuten die Risiken vor denen wir im
Moment stehen sind sind gigantisch es
ist ein unsichtbarer Krieg aber trotzdem
ein
Krieg es ist der 23 März
auf dem Sueskanal einer Schlagader der
globalen Wirtschaft kommt es zu einem
folgenschweren Zwischenfall an diesem
Tag passiert die evergiven den Kanal
eines der größten Containerschiffe der
Welt sie ist auf dem Weg von China nach
Rotterdam auf ihrer Fahrt nach Europa
muss das Schiff durch diese eine
Wasserstraße den Sueskanal über 10%
sämtlicher weltweit gehandelter Waren
passieren dieses nadelö
im Kontrollraum der Sues kanalbehörde
wird die Fahrt der evergiven
überwacht um 7 Uhr morgens hat mich der
dienstoffizier der Kontrollstelle
verständigt ein Schiff ist bei kilomeet
151 auf Grund
gelaufen in Rotterdam haben wir an
diesem Morgen gehört dass ein Schiff im
Sueskanal ein Problem hatte ich hielt
das für einen Schluck auf für mich war
das nicht weiter dramatisch doch es ist
mehr als nur ein schluckau nach einem
einzigen missglückten Manöver steht der
Koloss quer in der fahrin kein anderes
Schiff kommt mer vorbei nach nur wenigen
Stunden die Entscheidung der Kanal muss
gesperrt werden zum ersten Mal seit fast
Jahren in der jüngsten Geschichte des
sukanals ist das nicht vorgekommen nie
haben wir den sukanal tagelang sperren
müssen das ist noch nie
passiert nach 24 Stunden warten bereits
mehr als 100 Sch auf ein und müssen vor
Anker
gehen
aufal wichtige Verbindung auf der
handelsrute zwischen Asien und
Europa wir standen unter Druck vom eer
vom Räder von unserem Admiral und von
der ganzen
Welt vier winzige Bagger gegen ein
gigantisches Schiff mit 2000 Containern
an Bord es ist ein verzweifelter Kampf
der sechs Tage dauert aber als die
evergiven freikommt ist die Logistik in
den Häfen schon längst
zusammengebrochen dies setzt einen
weltweiten Dominoeffekt in
Gang es geht nicht um dieses eine Schiff
nicht um einen einzigen Vorfall dies war
kein Rotterdam Problem dies war ein
weltweites
Problem experten schätzen die
Folgekosten des Unfalls auf 10
Milliarden Dollar der Fall zeigt was
geschieht wenn das Versprechen nahloser
Warenströme nicht mehr eingelöst werden
kann es dauert knapp ein Jahr bis die
streng getakteten Lieferketten wieder
laufen es war ein Unfall dass die
evergiven im suis Kanal
stecken ein Rädchen im Getriebe das eine
Arterie verstopfte und zu einem
Herzstillstand
führte das könnte an vielen
Schlüsselstellen in der Welt passieren
ich denke die erste Lektion der ist das
System das wir seit 40 Jahren aufgebaut
haben extrem anfällig ist sobald man es
auf die Probe
stellt Abhängigkeit macht verwundbar
wenn die Zahnräder der Globalisierung
nicht mehr greifen ist das gerade für
Deutschland ein Problem unsere Computer
Drucker Smartphones und Tablets kommen
zu fast 100% aus dem Ausland genauso wie
viele Turnschuhe und Sofas Lebensmittel
Antibiotika und
Autoteile aber dieser Handel läuft in
beide Richtungen Deutschland ist
gleichzeitig Exportweltmeister im
Maschinenbau und bei chemischen
Produkten Luxusautos und
Spezialwerkzeugen Globalisierung
bedeutet ja für uns wir handeln wir
investieren wir beziehen Güter aus dem
Ausland wir exportieren Güter ins
Ausland wir beziehen Dienstleistungen
aus dem Ausland wir exportieren
Dienstleistungen ins Ausland und durch
die Globalisierung sind wir sehr eng
miteinander
verflochten als eröffnet Siemens 1904
ein Büro in
Shanghai in Mexiko rollt 1967 der erste
Käfer vom Band es ist der Beginn einer
weltweiten Erfolgsgeschichte für beide
Seiten die Globalisierung verschafft
deutschen Firmen günstige Arbeitskräfte
und Vorprodukte und wirtschaftlich
abgehängten Regionen im Laufe der
Jahrzehnte Aufschwung und Wohlstand
800 Millionen Menschen in China aus
bitterster Armut frei zu haben ist ein
Ergebnis der Globalisierung viele
glauben das ja nicht das nur gut für die
Reichen für die reichen Staaten ist es
gut Deutschland ist ein ein der ganz
großen Profiteure der Globalisierung wir
sind 50% unseres Wohlstands hängt am
Export Deutschland ist ABS ein absoluter
Gewinner der Globalisierung wir sind in
die Weltmärkte integriert wie fast kein
anderes Land in der Welt also für
Deutschland
schon in der Nachkriegszeit aber dann
auch 70er 80er Jahre und auch heute noch
ist die Globalisierung oder integ in die
Weltmärkte im ein gan eine ganz ganz
wichtige Säule für unseren Wohlstand
deshalb werden vor allem deutsche Firmen
zum Taktgeber dieser Entwicklung als
sich China zaghaft für die
Weltwirtschaft öffnet sind deutsche
Unternehmen sofort zur Stelle 1984
landet bundeskanzler Helmut KL in
Peking es herrscht
Goldgräberstimmung und kein Land Europas
wird der Art vom Aufstieg Chinas
profitieren wie Deutschland
aber deutschland und andere westliche
Staaten verfolgen mit der
internationalen wirtschaftlichen
Verflechtung noch ein zweites Ziel das
ist der politische Teil der
Globalisierung eine der großen
Hoffnungen die mit internationalem
Handel und Investition verbunden war ist
das Globalisierung und Öffnung eben
nicht nur zu wirtschaftlichen
wohlfahrtseffekten und
einkommenseffekten positiver Natur
führen sondern auch letztendlich zu
einer politischen Öffnung und
Demokratisierung von Ländern
letztendlich hat unsere
Außenwirtschaftspolitik und unsere
Außenpolitik also die deutsche lange
Zeit einem Motto oder einem Ideal
gefolgt und das ist der Glaube dass
Handel auch zu Wandel führen kann also
Handel fürrt zu Wandel Wandel durch
Handel auch deshalb gibt es jetzt kein
Halten mehr damit der wirtschaftliche
Teil dieses Modells funktioniert braucht
es immer wieder frisches Kapital mit der
ächst eine riesige Finanzindustrie sie
kommt vor allem aus New
York 1999 geht ein Unternehmen an die
Börse das 11 Jahre zuvor gegründet
wurde die Firma Blackrock saugt riesige
Summen auf und wird damit zum
Geburtshelfer der
hyperglobalisierung seit über 10 Jahren
ist Philip Hildebrand ehemaliger
Präsident der Schweizer Notenbank der
Vizechef von
Blackrock Gabbe damals den Big Bang also
die Liberalisierung der Kapitalmärkte
und durch diese Öffnung der
Kapitalmärkte auch von den Regularien
her konnte man dann sehr rasch diese
Globalisierung beschleunigen weil eben
auch das Kapital vorhanden war um
produktionsstädte praktisch auf der
ganzen Welt zu verteilen also die
Geschichte von Black Rock ist sowohl im
im entstehen wie auch später in der
Wirkung von Blackrock natürlich sehr eng
verbunden mit diesen kapitalflüssen die
dann wiederum die Globalisierung
ermöglicht haben mit dem Geld von
Blackrock beginnt ein neues Zeitalter
beinahe schrankenloser Handel
deregulierte Märkte und Profit um jeden
Preis das sind die Leitprinzipien denen
auch die westlichen Staatenlenker Folgen
bedingungslos kritiker werden abgebügelt
Globalisierung zum Naturgesetz
erklärt
genauso gut könnte man darüber
diskutieren ob der Herbst auf den Sommer
folgt die Globalisierung findet stad ob
es uns passt oder nicht die Frage ist
nur ob wir an ihr teilhaben werden oder
nicht ja wir können die Globalisierung
weder aufhalten noch abstellen sie ist
ökonomisch gesehen so etwas wie eine
Naturgewalt also es ist nicht so dass es
eine Naturgewalt ist politisch entweder
gewt oder nicht gewollt und lange Zeit
war die Überzeugung dass es so ein
trickle downown Effekt gibt also dass
die dies rausdrängen der Politik auf der
einen Seite dazu führt dass gewaltige
Gewinne gemacht werden können aber dass
die am Ende auch bei allen ankommen das
stimmt natürlich nicht PMA Sensen der
Pfalz wie an kaum einem anderen Ort in
Deutschland lässt sich zeigen dass die
Globalisierung auch ihre Schattenseiten
hat einst ist die St die Hochburg des
Schuhmacherhandwerks in den über 300
Schuhfabriken hier sind zu Hochzeiten 32
000 Menschen
beschäftigt aber die meisten Betriebe
gehen ein wegen der hohen Lohnkosten
müssen sie schließen oder verlagern ihre
Produktion ins Ausland zwischen 1978 und
2014 gehen in Pirmasens fast ein Drittel
aller Arbeitsplätze
verloren einige Firmen sind noch da
sowie die Bern Hummel Holding sie
residiert in einem frisch renovierten
Industriedenkmal bernthummel begann
seine Karriere als schuhfabrikant
1968 aber schon bald muss auch er
kämpfen gegen billige Konkurrenz aus dem
Ausland die Fabrik musste ich schließen
und einen neuen Weg einschlagen und der
hieß dann Schuhe aus Ungarn und
Bulgarien preiswertere Schuhe als die
die man hier produzieren kommte aber in
der Qualität eben nicht schlechter Bern
tummel surft mit auf der Welle der
Globalisierung seine Schuhmodelle
produziert er im Ausland seine Firma
floriert während Pirmasens bis heute
unter den Folgen der Globalisierung
leidet wenn du so eine hohe
Konzentration auf eine Industrie hast
dann ist es natürlich umso schmerzlicher
weil quasi alles betroffen ist davon
insofern war Globalisierung sicherlich
ein hartes Los für die Region und für
die
durch die Globalisierung gab es für
jeden Gewinner auch einen Verlierer und
es gibt definitiv große Teile der
Bevölkerung die zurückgelassen
wden von daher kommt natürlich auch sehr
stark diese der politische
Populismus eigentlich das politische
Streben gegen das Kapital weil einfach
zu viele Leute nicht profitiert haben
wir haben immer versucht in Deutschland
zu sagen wir wollen dieser
Globalisierung und vor allen der damit
verbundenen Effizienzsteigerung der
Produktivitätssteigerung nie
entgegenstehen auch wenn es
Arbeitsplätze
kostet ich glaube dass man diese
Entwicklungen einfach nicht aufhalten
kann das geht gar nicht und auch
zurückdrehen geht nicht also du kannst
heute nichtmer so tun als ob wir jetzt
19 Anfang 60 wären oder so das
funktioniert halt einfach
nicht die Firma von berel konzentert
sich heute vor allem auf die Produktion
der turnschuhmarke kangngaroos das niker
Design kommt aus pmasens produziert wird
in China und
Vietnam vor ein paar Jahren hat Hummel
eine kleine Fabrik in der Nähe gekauft
kangngaro sollen jetzt auch made in
Germany hergestellt werden in
Kleinserie natürlich ist es charmant
wenn man die Idee entwickelt marktnah zu
produzieren und auch was richtig gutes
produzieren zu wollen dann kostet aber
so ein Schuh ganz schnell mal über 300 €
im Laden die Idee bleibt eine
Liebhaberei Hummel produziert die
limitierte Auflage vor allem für Sammler
made in Germany ist ein
Verlustgeschäft mit dem was wir in
unserem großen Geschäft im
Importgeschäft verdienen können wir es
uns leisten quasi als marketing tool
diese kleine Schuhfabrik am Leben zu
erhalten aber in Deutschland ist so eine
Produktion absolut unrentabel er ist die
Arbeitsteilung macht das Unternehmen
Hummel profitabel das ist das magische
Rezept und die Globalisierung also doch
eine Naturgewalt ein automatischer
Prozess sie ist eine Naturgewalt solange
Vertrauen zwischen den Handelspartnern
herrscht deshalb ist es wichtig die
Globalisierung als eine Phase der
Geschichte zu betrachten die friedlich
war
und dann wird es eine kriegerische Phase
geben der russische Angriff auf die
Ukraine verändert
[Musik]
alles wir haben eben auch gerade erleben
müssen dass es Zeiten gibt in denen
nicht wirtschaftlicher Erfolg zählt
sondern die Ausdehnung geopolitischer
macht das glaube ich der wichtigste
Wechsel den wir gerade erleben dass
nicht mehr die geoökonomie den Vorrang
hat sondern wieder zurück sind in Zeiten
des Vorrangs der Geopolitik also
Geographie und macht sozusagen die
wieder versuchen den Vorrang zu bekommen
jetzt waren wir plötzlich über Nacht
wieder zurück in einer Welt wo die
Geopolitik wieder dominant wird und das
bedeutet natürlich dass seit diesem Tag
eigentlich die Wirtschaftsordnung wieder
sehr viel stärker auch auf Resilienz
schaut nicht nur auf Effizienz die ganze
Zeit dieser Globalisierung war
eigentlich komplett ausgerichtet wie
können wir ein möglichst effizientes
ökonomisches System bauen und plötzlich
dann über Nacht hat man realisiert das
genügt
nicht die Lenker von Blackrock die die
Globalisierung am schlagkräftigsten
befeuerten sind heute die größten
Warner denn der russische Angriffskrieg
hat die Grundfesten der Weltwirtschaft
endgültig erschüttert
ist dies der Beginn eines neuen
Zeitalters die Globalisierung ein
Auslaufmodell die Unternehmen könnten
die Handelsströme umleiten und neue
Partner suchen aber es stehen größere
Umwälzungen bevor denn die Weltordnung
in der wir leben ist im Wandel begriffen
in vielen politischen Diskussionen auch
getrieben durch die Vereinigten Staaten
sehen wir immer mehr diesen
systemwettbewerb Demokratien auf der
einen Seite im Vergleich zu einem ganz
anderen Modell nämlich einem
autokratischen Modell was eben nicht
offen ist was eben nicht gerecht ist und
diese beiden Systeme stehen sich immer
mehr gegenüber Autokratie Vers
Demokratie der Krieg richtet sich gegen
unsere Werte gegen unsere Zukunft es
geht um Autokratie gegen
Demokratie im Kampf zwischen Demokratie
und Autokratie stellen sich die
Demokratie in diesen Herausforderungen
und die Welt entscheidet sich eeutig für
Frieden und
Sicherheit mit den sich ändern
geopolitischen
Verhältnissen vor allen Dingen eben auch
Russlands Krieg gegen die
Ukraine machen wir uns deutlich mehr
Gedanken darüber mit wem wir in Zukunft
wirtschaftlich zu welchem Grad
verflochten sein wollen und eine Idee
ist die Idee einer wirtschaftlichen
Abkopplung von Autokratie insbesondere
eben auch von China wäre eine solche
Abkopplung für Deutschland überhaupt
möglich was wäre der Preis die Politik
ringt um eine
Position auch Wirtschaftsminister habck
muss erkennen dass der Leitspruch Wandel
durch Handel gescheitert ist und jetzt
macht man sich zum Komplizen wenn man
mit Diktaturen Geschäfte macht gerade
das Beispiel China zeigt freie Märkte
lassen sich auch mit unfreien Bürgern
bewirtschaften Deutschland steht vor
einem Dilemma wollen wir Werte oder
Wohlstand die Zeit wo wir immer nach
China verkaufen konnten und das Gas
immer günstig aus Russland kam und wir
daraus Wirtschaftsmodelle generieren
konnten sie ist erst einmal vorbei ich
persönlich glaube und das sage ich mit
großer Dringlichkeit und großem Ernst
dass diese Zeit eine Wasserscheiden Zeit
ist wir wissen nicht genau wie es in den
nächsten Jahren
weitergeht deswegen meine ich wir müssen
die Dinge anders machen und auch bereit
sein die Konsequenzen zu tragen für den
Grünen Wirtschaftsminister ist das ein
schmaler Grad jeder hier im Saal weiß
dass die deutsche Wirtschaft auf China
als Handelspartner nicht verzichten kann
und das gilt auch für andere Autokratien
denn sie sind die Wachstumsmärkte der
Zukunft es gibt
menschheitsherausforderungen die wir
nicht werden bewältigen können ohne auch
mit den Autokratien zusammenzuarbeiten
sozusagen zu glauben man könnte sagen
wir wollen überhaupt nicht miteinander
kooperieren sondern wir machen das nur
in der Demokratischen
Staatengemeinschaft wird nicht
funktionieren autokratische Staaten
haben zwischen 2018 und 2020 mehr
Auslandsinvestitionen erhalten als
demokratische Staaten auch bei den
Patenten holen sie
auf heute kommen 60% aller Patente aus
Ländern die autokratisch regiert
Autokratien unterschiedlicher Abstufung
sind die Motoren des
weltwirtschaftswachstums die Shanghai
Motorshow eine der größten Automessen
der Welt und für die deutschen Autobauer
die wichtigste denn China das rasant
wachsende Land mit 1,4 Milliarden
Einwohnern ist ihr größter
Absatzmarkt kein anderes deutes
Unternehmen hat sich mit seinem
Geschäftsmodell so abhängig von China
gemacht wie Volkswagen der Konzern
machte zuletzt fast 40% seines Umsatzes
in der Volksrepublik eine Abkehr
undenkbar Ralf Brandstätter leitet die
Geschäfte von VW China der
Volkswagenkonzern ist wichtiger
Bestandteil der chinesischen
Automobilindustrie und über 40 Millionen
Kunden fahren unsere Autos hier in dem
Markt und wir haben hier in China 40 und
beschäftigen 90.000 Beschäftigte und
damit sind wir das größte internationale
Industrieunternehmen in China und das
Wachstum geht weiter wir rechnen damit
dass bis 2030 beispielsweise dieser
Markt auf 28 Millionen Fahrzeuge wachsen
wird das sind noch mal 7 Millionen
Fahrzeuge alleine an zusätzlichem
Volumen 7 Millionen Fahrzeuge das ist
zweimal so groß wie der deutsche Markt
überhaupt ist doch der freie Handel
steht jetzt im Visier der Politik denn
im Wettstreit zwischen Demokratien und
Autokratien positioniert sich die
Bundesregierung neu Ministerin berbock
steht für eine Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik wir haben erläutert dass
wir es mit Sorge sehen dass freieräume
für zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement
in China immer weiter schrumpfen und
Menschenrechte beschnitten werden um
Erziehung
Zwangsarbeit und totale
Überwachung in der Provinz shinjiang
geht der chinesische Staat mit unfassbar
Härte gegen die muslimische Volksgruppe
der Uiguren
vor in der Region sind auch deutsche
Firmen aktiv unter anderem
VW natürlich kennen wir auch die
Berichte zur Menschenrechtssituation in
China und das hat jeden von uns
natürlich auch betroffen gemacht auf der
anderen Seite sind für uns
Menschenrechte eben auch nicht verhandel
egal in welchem Werk
wir weltweit operieren und das gilt eben
auch für China 2013 eröffnete VW ein
Werk in der uigurenprovinz auf Drängen
der chinesischen Regierung das war vor
der massiven staatlichen
Unterdrückung lange versucht VW die Lage
auszublenden inzwischen lässt sich das
tiefe Dilemma nicht mehr
ignorieren für mich war es wichtig mir
vor Ort schnell ein Bild zu machen
anfangs hat Corona die Reisetätigkeit
beschränkt als es dann möglich war war
ich sofort vor Ort und habe mir ein Bild
gemacht und habe keine anlasspunkte
gefunden dass wir hier
Menschenrechtsverletzung in unserem Werk
haben und wir haben ja letztendlich auch
entschieden ein Audit in diesem Werk
durchzuführen vW hat diese unabhängige
Untersuchung trotz des staatlichen
chinesischen Mitgesellschafters im Werk
durchgesetzt das Ergebnis keine Hinweise
auf
Zwangsarbeit doch was taugen solche
Untersuchungen angesichts systematischer
Menschenrechtsverbrechen das ist eine
Frage die auch die deutsche Politik
umtreibt die deutsche chinaastategie in
der
Klemme auf der einen Seite möchte man
die wirtschaftliche Verflechtung mit
China braucht sie auch für unseren
eigenen Wohlstand auf der anderen Seite
möchten wir das Modell wie es wie China
es hat ja auch nicht unterstützen das
ist das wie wir China sehen als als als
Partner als Wettbewerber und als
systemrivevale als Außenministerin
berbock Peking besucht trifft sie auch
Ralf Brandstetter der VW Manager ist
jetzt fast so etwas wie der langearm der
Regierung denn er muss die Inhalte der
neuen deutschen chinapolitik mittragen
der darin formulierte Dreiklang ist ein
Balanceakt die Strategie der
Bundesregierung die ist auf der einen
Seite ja pragmatisch die setzt weiterhin
auf partnerschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
aber sie sieht eben auch
Risikominimierung vor und für mich ist
dieser Dreiklang auch völlig in Ordnung
wenn es denn beim Dreiklang bleibt
wichtig ist glaube ich dass wir uns
nicht bei dem Thema
Risikominimierung nur zu stark darauf
konzentrieren dass Handel mit China
plötzlich automatisch mit Risiko
gleichgesetzt wird für uns ist China
eine Art frenemy Freund und Gegner
zugleich ökonomischer Partner und
politischer Gegner wir suchen nach einem
Umgang mit China bei dem wir jetzt nicht
die totale Konfrontation suchen aber uns
auch nicht in Abhängigkeit von China
begeben wollen das ist ein nicht ganz
einfacher Weg der Handel mit China
bleibt ein zweischneidiges Schwert
deutsche Unternehmen müssen selbst
entscheiden ob sie es sich weiter
leisten wollen hier alles auf eine Karte
zu setzen Volkswagen kann gar nicht
anders China bleibt für den Konzern
riesiger Markt und VW ist nicht
allein insgesamt 5200 deutsche
Unternehmen sind in China tätig sie
benötigen dringend die in China
hergestellten Vorprodukte oder können
auf China als Absatzmarkt kaum
verzichten 2022 haben Deutschland und
China Waren im Wert von 300 Milliarden
Euro miteinander
ausgetauscht China ist damit zum siebten
Mal infolge wichtigster Handelspartner
und auch die Investitionen deutscher
Unternehmen in China sind auf einem
Allzeithoch die ökonomischen
Verflechtungen zwischen beiden Ländern
gehen nicht
zurück
taip die Hauptstadt Taiwans derzeit
einer der gefährlichsten geopolitischen
Brennpunkte der Welt den nahezu
unbemerkt von der breiten Öffentlichkeit
hat der Inselstaat in den letzten Jahren
ein quasi Monopol für hochmodernste
Computerchips
geschaffen und damit die ganze Welt von
sich abhängig gemacht dabei wird um
etwas nahezu unsichtbares
gerungen Halbleiter und Computerchips
die winzigen Bauteile sind das Herzstück
moderner Industrieprodukte obwohl wir es
kaum merken unser modernes Leben ist
ohne sie kaum
denkbar von dem Moment an an dem Sie
morgens aufwachen bis zu dem Moment an
dem sie schlafen gehen haben sie Alltag
mit tausenden von Halbleitern zu tun in
ihrem Auto in Ihrem Kühlschrank ihrer
Mikrowelle Ihrem iPhone in Ihrem
Computer Tag für Tag kommen wir mit
tausenden von diesen Chips in Berührung
und plötzlich wird einem klar dass dies
ein Teil der Weltwirtschaft ist von dem
alles andere abhängt und über den wir
bisher kaum nachgedacht
haben der us-htoriker Chris Miller sieht
Computerchips und Halbleiter als
wichtigsten Rohstoff unserer Zeit für
ihn sind diese ile das neue Öl W den
Zugang zu ihnen kontrolliert
kontrolliert die Welt Computerchips sind
heute in allem drin deshalb kann man
weder die moderne Wirtschaft noch die
internationale Politik verstehen ohne
die Produktion dieser Rechnerkapazitäten
in den Mittelpunkt seine Analyse zu
stellen rushour vor den Touren von
taip die Hightech Arbeiterschaft des
Landes ist auf dem Weg in die
Fabriken im ganzen Land Reiz sich eine
halbliter Produktionsstätte an die
nächste Taiwan stellt jedes Jahr zwei
Drittel aller weltweit gefertigten
Computerchips her und knapp 90% der
ultramodernen Halbleiter der neuesten
Generation die meisten stammen von
dieser Firma
TSMC wahrscheinlich ist es das
wichtigste Unternehmen der Welt von dem
die wenigsten Menschen jemals gehört
haben aktueller Marktwert knapp 4
Milliarden EUR damit zählt TSMC zu den
ze wertvollsten Unternehmen der Welt und
zu den verschwiegensten Dreharbeiten
sind untersagt TSMC Mitarbeiter geben so
gut wie keine Interviews in den
Innenräumen der Fabriken darf nicht
gefilmt
werden eine hochmoderne
halbleiterpoduktionsanlage kostet 20 bis
25 Milliarden Dollar nur eine Anlage
sogar das US-Militär das über ein Budget
von 850 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr
verfügt entschied vor einem jahrzehn
selbst keine Chips herzustellen weil das
zu teuer
ist auch apple nutzt für seine neuesten
iPhones Halbleiter made in Taiwan aber
Apple kann sie nicht herstellen denn es
sind die kleinsten Halbleiter Chips der
Welt in jedem der hauptchips eines neuen
iPhones werden 10 bis 15 Milliarden
winzige Transistoren eingearbeitet sein
nur ein Unternehmen auf der Welt kann
diese essentiellen Chips in diesem
winzigen Maßstab und den erforderlichen
Mengen für ein iPhone herstellen
TSMC es gibt keine einzige Firma in den
USA die diese Chips herstellen könnte
und auch keine in China keine in Europa
keine in Japan die modernsten Chips von
Apple können nur von einer einzigen
Firma hergestellt werden in einem
einzigen Gebäude in der teuersten Fabrik
der Menschheitsgeschichte an diesem Ort
in der Fabrik Nummer 18 von
TSMC dieser technologische Vorsprung und
die damit verbundene Abhängigkeit ist
politisch gewollt der stellvertretende
Außenminister sieht sie als Teil von
Taiwans nationaler
Strategie vor 40 Jahren diewanesische
Regierung sich auf die Herstellung von
halitern zu
spezialisieren sie haben vor 40 Jahren
erwartet was heute passiert und richtig
vorher gesehen dass sich das
Weltgeschehen um Halbleiter drehen
wird bislang war diese Konzentration für
die Weltwirtschaft kein Problem aber
jetzt steht die taiwanesische
Chipproduktion im Zentrum des wohl
größten geoökonomischen risikoszenarios
der Gegenwart denn Taiwan das von der
Volksrepublik China als abtröige Provinz
gesehen wird rechnet jederzeit mit einem
Angriff
wir haben aus der Ukraine gelernt dass
ein autoritäres Regime insbesondere in
China mehr als nur autoritär ist China
ist auf dem Weg zu einem totalitären
Regime sie haben sehr verzerrte
Entscheidungen getroffen die auf
verzerrten Weltanschauungen
beruhen also ja Taiwan und alle anderen
sollten angesichts dieser Tatsache nicht
naiv sein wir sind uns bewusst dass ein
totalitäres Regime wie China
unvorhersehbare verrückte Entscheidungen
trifft um Taiwan
anzugreifen die Angst ist groß unter den
Bürgern von Taiwan Seminare zum
Zivilschutz sind auf Monate
ausgebucht viele hier rechnen damit dass
ein Angriff von China jederzeit
passieren könnte sie fühlen sich
schutzlos
Hysterie wohl kaum denn der chinesische
Präsident shijing Ping spricht immer
wieder davon
wir werden uns aufrichtig bemühen dass
die Vereinigung mit Taiwan friedlich
abläuft doch schließen wir den Einsatz
von Gewalt nicht aus und behalten uns
vor alle erforderlichen Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen das ist ein chinraum er hat es
mehrfach gesagt seine hochrangige
Führung soll für das Jahr 2027 eine
militärinvasion gegen Taiwan vorbereiten
deshalb sagen die westlichen
Geheimdienste dass 2027 ein gefährliches
Jahr für uns
ist schon jetzt probt die chinesische
Armee Angriffe auf Taiwan beinah im
wochenrhthmus dringt sie in
taiwanesischen Luftraum oder Gewässer
ein es sind Manöver die jederzeit außer
Kontrolle geraten
könnten
in den letzten Jahren konnten wir viele
verschiedene Arten von Flugzeugen sehen
Düsenjäger Bomber aber auch
Marineschiffe sie halten gemeinsame
Übungen auf der Ostseite Taiwans ab das
ist ein sehr deutliches Zeichen sie
wollen ein warnignal an die Welt senden
dass eine militärische Invasion
wahrscheinlich
ist weil die ganze Welt abhängig ist von
Computerchips aus Taiwan könnten sie dem
Inselstaat als Faustpfand
dienen aber werden sie als
Sicherheitsgarantie
funktionieren wenn es zu einer
militärischen Krise zwischen China und
Taiwan käme die die Lieferkette von
Chips unterbricht würde die
Weltwirtschaft einen Einbruch erleben
den es seit der Großen Depression nicht
mehr gegeben hat weitaus verheerender
als der russland-ukraine Krieg ich denke
dass ein Faktor 10 die Auswirkungen
unterschätzt und ganz einfach wir sind
nicht darauf
vorbereitet taiwan hat mit seiner
Chipproduktion eine Herzkammer der
Hightech
ier sollten keine Halbleiter Chips aus
Taiwan mehr geliefert werden stünde die
Wirtschaft still auch in
Deutschland und der Konflikt verschärft
sich weiter denn die USA verwieren China
den Zugang zu dieser
Schlüsseltechnologie auch andere
westliche Staaten beteiligen sich an dem
Embargo ein
Frontalangriff
die die USA und China befinden sich
eindeutig in einem Wirtschaftskrieg die
technologischen die die Vereinten
Staaten vornehmen sind eine Form von
ressourcennationalismus ich nenne es
techn Nationalismus jeder schränkt ein
was er hat und kontrolliert wie du mir
so ich dir diese Eskalation wird nicht
enden bis es einen ultimativen Hegemon
an der Spitze der Hierarchie gibt ich
denke dass jeder seine stärksten Karten
ausspielt in Nordfrankreich auf der
Baustelle der modernsten gigaory
europason bald wird hier das Herzstück
der Elektromobilität hergestellt Litium
ienbatterien für die E-Fahrzeuge
benötigt man mehrere hundert solcher
Batteriezellen die hier demnächst vom
Band laufen werden bislang kann kein
einziger deutscher Autobauer eigene
Batteriezellen verbauen alle sind bei
diesem entscheidenden Bauteil auf
Zulieferer angewiesen keiner produziert
sie selbst Mercedes bekam die Folgen
Ende 2023 zu spüren weil der
Hauptlieferant für Batterien ausfiel
verlor der Autobauer über 5 Milliarden
Euro
Umsatz die Autohersteller brauchen diese
gigafory so schnell wie möglich deshalb
beeilen wir uns hier so sehr es ist ein
Projekt zur reindustrialisierung Europas
und Frankreichs im Besonderen es ist ein
sehr wichtiges Projekt für die
Wiedererlangung der
Souveränität an der G ist Mercedes jetzt
beteiligt aber auch mit eigener
batteriezellfertigung bleiben die
deutschen Autobauer
abhängig denn für die Produktion
benötigt man fünf essentielle Rohstoffe
die Beschaffung auf dem globalisierten
Markt lief problemlos
bisher hinter den Kulissen einer
Spezialabteilung der deutschen
rohstoffagentur diese Fachleute der
Bundesanstalt für Geowissenschaften
versorgen mit ihren Expertisen auch die
deutsche Regierung ihre Analysen sind
gefragter den je kaum jemand hat sich so
intensiv mit den Realitäten der
Rohstoffversorgung beschäftigt genau wir
haben jetzt noch die aktuelle Situation
der batterierohstoff Litium ist
besonders kritisch unsere Szenarien
zeigen dass der Bedarf an Litium sich
bis 2030 mindestens verdreifachen
vervierfachen wird und bis 2040 und etwa
ver sechfachen wird das Angebot kommt
dieser Nachfrage aber nicht schnell
genug hinterher das heißt dass wir bis
2030 voraussichtlich schon eine
litiumlücke haben werden also eine
Versorgungslücke bei Litium Litium
Endprodukte für Batteriezellen werden im
Moment zu großen Teilen von China
hergestellt diese Marktkonzentration ist
gefährlich deshalb ist Eile geboten auch
bei allen anderen
batterierohstoffen wenn man davon
ausgeht dass ich die Bedarfe so wie
prognostiziert steigern werden dann
werden wir zwischen 20 30 und 2040 noch
mal einen Stärken Anstieg in
litiiumbedarf kobaltbedarf graffitbedarf
manganbedarf nickelbedarf sehen wenn wir
zur CO2 Neutralität kommen weren auch
durch die Verkehrswende dann wird es
diesen Druck geben dieses diesen
Hochlauf hinzubekommen und das geht nur
wenn die Bergbauprojekte und
Explorationsprojekte die jetzt alle in
der Planung sind dann auch tatsächlich
an den Start gehen unterwegs im
äußersten Süd Osten Finnlands unweit der
russischen Grenze wenige andere Orte in
Europa sind so reich an Bodenschätzen
ein Eldorado für
rohstoffjäger auch für den Geologen
Roberto Garcia Martinz mit seiner Firma
hat er sich auf batteriineralien
spezialisiert solche Rohstoffe die
derzeit auf der ganzen Welt gesucht
werden bei seinen Erkundungen ist der
rohstoffjäger auf eine stillgelegte mene
gestoßen bis 1989 wurde hier Kobalt
gefördert zu Hochzeiten kamen fast 10%
der weltweiten Fördermenge aus Finnland
aber die mene wurde aufgegeben die
Nachfrage war gering die Preise im
Keller heute ist Kobalt ein zentraler
Rohstoff für die
batterieherstellung in unserer Mine hier
in Finnland haben wir sehr hohe
kobaltgehalte diese mene wird die erste
kobaltmiene sein die in den letzten 10
Jahren in Nordeuropa in Betrieb genommen
wurde
die Probebohrungen zur Erkundung
weiterer Abbaustollen sind in vollem
Gange schon bald kann die
kobaltförderung hier beginnen aber es
ist nur einer der Rohstoffe für die
mobilitätswende und selbst dem Team von
Garcia Martinez ist klar die
förderpotenziale in Europa sind
winzig nur 2% der batteriemineralien
werden heute innerhalb Europas
hergestellt 9% außerhalb das ist von
entscheidender Bedeutung und sehr
gefährlich denn das Rohmaterial für die
gesamte europäische Industrie liegt in
den Händen von sehr wenigen
Ländern es ist für die Industrie von
entscheidender Bedeutung dass wir die
Oberhand behalten und die Kontrolle
darüber nicht
verlieren laut europäischer Kommission
gelten aktuell insgesamt 34 Mineralien
und seltene Erden als kritische Stoffe
jüngsten Studien zufolge war Deutschland
bei 23 davon zu 100% abhängig von
Einfuhren vor allem bei den Rohstoffen
zur Umsetzung der Energiewende ist die
deutsche Industrie auf China
angewiesen eine Eigenversorgung bei den
batterierohstoffen werden wir in Europa
nicht erreichen nicht auf absehbare Zeit
das heißt wir werden weiterhin hohe
importabhängigkeiten haben und dadurch
natürlich auch die entsprechenden
Risiken dass es unter bestimmten
Umständen zu lieferstops
Exportbeschränkungen exportstops
ähm in den Rohstoffmärkten geben kann
lieferstops können dazu führen dass die
Bänder in den Fabriken auch in
Deutschland zum Stillstand
kommen ohne Minen gibt es keine
Elektroautos und ohne Elektroautos keine
Verkehrswende deshalb macht die Jagd
nach Rohstoffen in Europa Sinn doch
schon jetzt ist klar diese vorkommen
werden nicht reichen um einen vollkommen
neuen Industriezweig zu speisen wir
sehen eine große Gefahr darin dass wir
von den autokratisch diktatorischen
Staaten auch in Zukunft stärker abhängig
sein können und gleichzeitig müssen wir
in den demokratisch humanistischen
Strukturen in denen wir leben ähm
aufpassen dass wir von Versorgung nicht
abgeschnitten werden die beste Art der
Krisenbewältigung ist immer die
Kooperation wenn der Handelskrieg
zwischen China und dem Westen sich
verschärft könnte China seine
Vorherrschaft bei Rohstoffen als Waffe
einsetzen erste Anzeichen dafür gibt es
bereits 2023 hat Peking Exportkontrollen
für drei essentielle Rohstoffe verhängt
china könnte uns an der Stelle in
Geiselhaft nehmen und es schränkt
unseren politischen Spielraum eben auch
ein bestimmte Dinge was China macht eben
auch zu sanktionieren die eskalations
Gefahr die wir zur Zeit beobachten ist
riesig groß und wird mit großen großen
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
Verlusten einhergehen wenn man weiß wir
wollen jetzt alles elektrisch machen die
dafür nötigen Mineralien sind aber im
chinesischen Besitz und die dafür
nötigen Industrien auch
also wir werden schon miteinander
umgehen müssen und das Problem ist ja
nicht dass China eine geopolitische
Strategie hat so dass wir keine haben
also wer glaubt nur mit normativen
Ansprüchen die Welt zu verändern der
wird scheitern und der wird nicht nur im
Wohlstand scheitern sondern wird auch
politisch scheiter die Politik hat
dazuelernt sie will Deutschland
absichern und plant deshalb wie hier bei
Magdeburg den Bau einer Chipfabrik damit
soll Deutschlands eigenversorgungsquote
steigen von derzeit 10 auf
20%. nach dem evergiven Unglück hatten
sich die Lieferketten wieder halbwegs
eingespielt nun drohen Raketen der hui
Milizen Handelsschiffe im Roten
Meer die Weltordnung formiert sich neu
deshalb steht auch die Weltwirtschaft am
Scheideweg manche sprechen sogar von
einem neuen unsichtbaren
Krieg in diesem Krieg gibt es eine Reihe
unsichtbarer
Frontlinien dazu gehören Technologie
Rohstoffe und Finanzen Ken sie wirklich
sehen sie kommen nicht in den
Abendnachrichten vor also denken wir
auch nicht darüber nach aber es sind
Frontlinien in einem brutalen Krieg
zwischen
Großmächten ich glaube dass wir heute
viel brutalere Kriege führen als während
des Kalten Krieges und das sollte uns
nachts
wachhalten
[Musik]